hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical applications and
strategies using procalcitonin to
improve patient outcomes presented by
dr. Eric cluck director of critical
services Swedish covenant hospital
I'm Cindy Valdez Roberts and I'll be
your moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labyrinth is
sponsored by Abbott Abbott is committed
to helping you live your best possible
life through the power of Health for
more than 125 years they've brought new
products and technologies to the world
in nutrition Diagnostics medical devices
and branded generic pharmaceuticals all
creating more possibilities for more
people at all stages of life in more
than 150 countries 94,000 Abbott team
members are working to help people live
not just longer but better and for over
40 years
Ovid has committed to delivering the
highest quality products to serve our
hepatitis in vitro diagnostics community
for more information please visit
Abbott's calm before we begin I'd like
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on the green
Q&A button located at the lower left of
the presentation window and type your
questions into the box that appear on
the screen well answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation also notice you're viewing
this presentation in a slide window to
enlarge that window just click on the
screen icon located at the lower right
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button at the top right or
use a Q&A button and let us know you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits click on the button in
the bottom left hand corner and follow
the process to obtain your credit
now I'd like to introduce our presenter
today dr. Erica Gluck dr. Eric cluck
received his medical degree in medicine
from New York Medical College in New
York he completed his residency at Beth
Israel Medical Center in New York City
and a pulmonary fellowship at the
University of Utah School of Medicine he
currently serves as a director of
critical care care services and chief
academic officer as the Swedish Covenant
Hospital in Chicago Illinois in addition
dr. Gluck is a professor of medicine at
the French University of Health Sciences
at the Chicago Medical Center dr. Clark
is part of many professional societies
most notably he is a fellow of the
Society of critical care medicine the
American College of Chest Physicians and
the Chicago Institute of Medicine he's a
member of the American Thoracic Society
Alpha Omega Alpha and the American
Society of law medicine and ethics he
has presented lectures and authored many
peer-reviewed articles and chapters in
the field of pulmonary critical care and
has been in practice for more than 20
years more recently dr. Glock has been a
leader at developing and implementation
strategies at an institution to reduce
the risk of sepsis in critically ill
patients join me and welcome in here
today welcome dr. Gluck well thank you
for that introduction a pleasure to be
here and I want to thank Abbott for
inviting me to talk on a subject that is
very near and dear to my heart
so basically we're going to talk about
the clinical applications and strategies
to use a relatively new biomarker to
improve patient outcomes in sepsis my
disclosures are that I give lectures
about biomarkers for sepsis for multiple
different companies but I am not an
employee of any of them okay so these
are the contents we're going to talk a
little bit about the background for
biomarkers in sepsis diagnostic tools to
make us
better at identifying patients and with
infections hopefully earlier we'll talk
a little bit about how we can use these
biomarkers for more appropriate usage of
antibiotics and finally we'll end with
some case studies which I think will
hopefully elucidate some of the points
and I'm going to make during this talk
substance is a big deal
there are about 1.6 million people who
are diagnosed with sepsis every year
translates to one every 20 seconds in
the hospitals it is the leading cause of
death when you look at causes of
mortality and costs substance is a
unbelievably significant problem it's
increasing every year the cost of taking
care of patients is increasing every
year looking at somewhere in the range
of 20 to 30 billion dollars estimate for
this year or over the next three to four
years so quite significant mortality
rate 21.5%
measured about a decade ago the
currently estimates of about fourteen
point seven percent but that includes
all forms of sepsis patients with severe
sepsis and septic shock the ones who are
more likely to end up in the hospital
and the intensive care unit average
mortality for those patients somewhere
in the high 20s to low 30
but even when you think about fourteen
point seven percent that's that's one in
six - one in seven people with sepsis
succumbing to it so why is this a
problem and why can't we do better well
first of all we are doing a lot better
if you go back five decades when
antibiotics and I see use first became
significant the mortality rate for
septic shock and severe sepsis was in
the eighty to ninety percent range so we
are doing better but why can't we
any better the problem is is that we
have this very complex relationship with
bacteria we coexist with about five
trillion that's what that number works
out to be five trillion bacteria we have
eight trillion cells of our own and so
there is almost as many bacteria in our
body as our own personal cells if we
have this great relationship though with
them the good guys help us we they are
essential for survival they help with
digestion they help with manufacturing
certain chemicals that we cannot do on
our own
they actually protect us from more evil
bacteria and if we keep the situation in
check this is a perfectly mutual
beneficial relationship they won't harm
us we won't harm them everyone coexists
with great daytime's the problem is is
that this system doesn't always stay in
check and this is not the only way that
we can become infected we don't always
become infected from bacteria that are
in our system in fact most people would
have not even thought about those most
people talk about the infections that
come from outside the one you get from
somebody who you're at a party and all
of a sudden they coffin all sorts of
bacteria viruses get expelled and
becomes airborne and are potentially
causing somebody else an infection back
in the day as we like to say infection
was based mostly on a gut feeling doc
went up to the bedside looked at the
patient got a couple of rudimentary lab
tests and decided that the patient was
infected corroboration of this was very
poor there was very little objective
evidence nobody really understood the
sensitivity of specificity of white cell
count anemia fevers everyone just
assumed they were very good correlating
positive cultures was very poor only
about one in three patients with
bacterial sepsis had a positive culture
of any sort and so basically if the
clinician thought you were infected you
are infected and if you got better with
air
products that was a success in the
antibiotics if you didn't then it was a
failure for the antibiotics but
nonetheless you were still infected as
it turns out we finally learned in the
9019 90s that those biomarkers the white
count fever and Vandermeer were not as
specific for infections as we really had
hoped they would be the second problem
with antibiotics was that they were
basically prescribed by a regimen people
received antibiotics for seven days 10
days 14 days and then they were stopped
so antibiotic regimens were prescribed
they weren't titrated and and we now
understand that this is not optimal
patients present with a different load
of bacteria in their body and therefore
might need therapy for a different
duration of time patients also have
their own personal medical history and
as such they may be better or worse at
defending themselves against an
infection and so we need regimens that
are based on response not based on a
prescribed duration and the previous
tests that we used were not able to
discern how long to give antibiotics for
in an individual person the severity of
an infection varies from person to
person most importantly it all depends
on the immuno competency of the patient
and when I talk about immuno competency
I'm not just talking about whether a
person has a disease like leukemia or
lymphoma that might adversely affect the
person's ability to defend themselves
against an infection yeah we those are
part of the process but people have
recently had an infection they're immuno
competence he may have not have been
fully just restored yet elderly patients
patients who are malnourished patients
who have alcohol problems all those
patients may have a different level of
Imperial competency and therefore may
respond to an infection differently how
long it takes for the patient to present
to a health care provider may also
change the severity so a pneumonia
could be very easy to treat if the
patient presents early on much more
difficult if he or she waits at home for
three or four days because the size of
the bacterial burden will vary and this
will vary depending on how long the
patient takes to present how that how
many bacteria the patient initially got
infected with and how well the on their
own immune system can defend itself
obviously the site of infection is
important there are certain areas of the
body where infections are relatively
routine and the body can handle them
that would be the GI tract there are
other places where the body can't handle
them at all that would be the cerebral
spinal fluid area so meningitis and
encephalitis are very bad pneumonia is
somewhere in between and of course we
already talked about the nutritional and
functional status has been very very
important in how well somebody could
defend themselves against an infection
so the duration of antibiotic therapy
should be dictated by response so we we
need something to tell us what this
response is we also now know that white
cells and the other biomarkers that we
used are not sensitive nor specific
enough to clearly identify all the
patients who have infection and those
patients who don't have infection in
fact one of the criteria that we use
we'll talk about this a little bit later
service criteria it turns out two-thirds
of the patients have these criteria but
only 25% of patients in the ICU are
infected so how does the body know when
there's an infection going on well this
is a depiction of the cell and over here
is the cell wall and on the cell wall we
have these respectives they're sort of
like antennae fluttering in the fluid
between ourselves the interstitial fluid
and they're looking for bacteria living
bacteria dead bacteria parts of bacteria
innards of bacteria and
they there are actually 12 of these
receptors eight of them are external for
them an internal they will respond by
creating a biochemical reaction when
they encounter a bacteria this whole
idea is to turn this cell into a
bacteria fighting machine but also to
warn other back other cells in the
neighborhood that they are under attack
so they send out a signal to other cells
nearby and that's where these
inflammatory cytokines come as you can
see over here that's where they come
into play these will respond and they
will do things inside the cell to turn
it into a killing machine and also leak
out of the cell and go to other cells to
tell the other cells that there is an
invading bacteria in the neighborhood
now the problem that the body has is
that we have bacteria throughout our
body in different situations we already
talked about these guys over here these
are called commensal bacteria these are
the guys who are friends and as long as
they are in the right numbers in the
right place they really can't do us any
harm in fact they help the only time
they could become problematic is if we
change the environment and that allows
them to grow out of proportion to what
they should when that happens or if the
barrier to that is changed like you see
over here
well then they can actually invade our
body and cause us of infection you may
have had a friend or a family member or
know about C difficile infections C
difficile is a bacteria that's in our
colon and typically does us no harm
unless the environment in the colon has
changed and then it can become a
devastating infection and you can see
that the body's response to this is
pro-rated of course we have these
pathogens that can get into us some of
them are very weak they require some
additional change in the environment
caused an infection and then we also so
those are the faculty pathogens and in
fact a lot of people think that those
are the ones that are the bacteria that
people encounter in the ICU and stuff
like that those are the bacteria that
require debilitated hosts for them to
get going the pathogens over here are
the ones that you can get by writing
next to somebody on a train or a bus and
they cough on you and so sometimes we
sort of treat those because they're so
easy to get outside the hospital as less
important than the ones that you get
inside the hospital but nothing could be
further from the truth and then you can
see that the response of the body to
these bacteria is significantly
different than the previous responses
and again there is this dose response
curve the body recognizes initially just
a little bit of cell wall and then there
is this response that is limited if they
see dead bacteria then the response
starts to increase if they see live
bacteria then you can see that the
response is really quite robust and then
when you have these pathogens that can
produce toxins as well then the response
is really quite dramatic
honey understands this and what we need
to do to really understand when there's
an infection is to tap into this
resource there is an infection when the
body thinks there is an infection and so
if we could look into these chemical
responses and find one of them that we
could measure easily and accurately that
would help us identify an infection when
the body thought there was an infection
because when there is an infection as
you can see here the bacteria excites
these pathways I talked about on the
cell and a whole chemical reaction
occurs leaking stuff out of the cell and
causing further proteins to be made in
the Nuuk
and these responses are very very
specific to the bacteria so not only do
we know that there's a bacterial
infection but the body sort of knows
which bacteria it is that is causing the
infection in addition there to this
nuclear response is as you can see on
this slide here the release now the
release of these substances basically is
what gives you the fever that chills the
elevation and the white count the change
in cardiac function all of those changes
are there in an attempt to defend
against an infection the problem is that
those same chemicals to some degree are
released whether there's a bacterial
infection or whether there's
inflammation as is depicted over here so
here when there's information we get the
same response and so initially the body
doesn't discern the difference between a
sterile inflammation and a bacterial
inflammation in fact it responds just
like the fire department does if you
pull the fire along the fire the fire
guy gets on the phone he doesn't ask you
what kind of fire it is he doesn't ask
you if it's a big fire a small fire
electrical fire gas pie or anything like
that he just says where's the fire and
they send everybody there and once they
figured out what's going on they will
decide who needs to participate and who
does not well that's exactly what the
body does whether there's federal
information or bacterial infection the
body responds as if it was a bacterial
infection because that's the thing that
can do it the most harm and that's why a
fever a white count an elevation in band
count are nonspecific because the body
responds to that whether there's an
infection or not so once again what
we're trying to do is tap into these
biochemical pathways because those are
the ones that are much more specific for
an infection
so as I was saying the the immune system
doesn't always differentiate between
sepsis and damage one because it's a bad
evolutionary mistake to allow bacteria
to reproduce rapidly without defending
against them and number two it doesn't
make a lot of difference if we waste
some resources initially eventually we
can get a signal that it's much more
sequencing specific and sensitive so
what are we going to do to tap into this
whoa
initially procalcitonin was identified
as a precursor to calcitonin which
lowers serum calcium after and calcium
low that you might get from eating a
meal that's rich in dairy products as it
turns out procalcitonin
has a use that is much more significant
and actually predated this it is one of
those chemicals released by the body by
the cells specifically in response to
bacteria it does not respond to viruses
it does not respond to protozoa it
doesn't respond to any other infecting
agents except bacteria and some fungi
which have been able to fool our body
into thinking they're really a bacteria
so for all intensive purposes this
procalcitonin signal identifies with
high degree of sensitivity and
specificity bacterial bacterial
infections it has been demonstrated over
the last two and a half decades to to
give us a dose response to the severity
of infections when the infections are
very localized the levels are just
modestly elevated less than point one is
considered normal
so in local infections
you almost cannot discern a signal
because the levels are so close to
normal as they would be very difficult
statistically to discern it as the local
infection spreads and becomes more
significant the levels will become
clearly elevated most people consider
0.5 0 to be clearly elevated and then as
you progress to sepsis and severe sepsis
and then ultimately septic shock the
levels get higher and higher so not only
is this a signal of infection it also is
a signal of the severity of the
infection and it is a signal of severity
infection not based on what the
clinician sees in the patient but based
on what the body perceives is going on
and the body is a much better observer
than the clinician now you have to
understand the kinetics of this
biomarker to understand how to use it
there are other cytokines we talked
about them in general that are produced
during an infection aisle 6
aisle 10 and TNF are prepackaged in the
cell and they are released virtually
immediately as you can see here the time
line they go up almost immediately to a
level that is detectable procalcitonin
and the other biomarker CRP they don't
go up right away there is a delay so it
is possible for a patient to actually
present early in sepsis and have a
normal PCT level or CRP so we need to
get two levels of PCT at least 6 hours
apart in order to be sure that the
levels are negative but here is the
beauty of PCT unlike the other
biomarkers that we talked about il-6
will disappear very rapidly as will
aisle tenant E&M which means that the
patient presents late it may not have a
signal
that we can see anymore so PCT and CRP
becomes signals that start a little bit
later but lasts as long as the patients
infected and so they become very useful
in identifying patients with sepsis in
this chart here we did a sensitivity and
specificity analysis of the different
biomarkers here we used procalcitonin C
reactive protein
l6 and lactate now let's dispel with
lactate lactate is a wonderful biomarker
although it looks poor in this study and
that's because lactate is not specific
for infection lactate is specific for
perfusion defects so when a patient has
hypoperfusion of organs the lactate
level goes up that may be sepsis but it
could also be heart failure it could
also be trauma and so that's why it
didn't show great sensitivity and
specificity as you can see here il-6 and
CRP did pretty well
CRP has a problem in that it is also
slightly less specific because it will
go up in sterile inflammation of the
biomarkers that we're testing PCT had
the best receiver operating
characteristic so it had the best
sensitivity and the best specificity
okay we talked about all these different
kinds of descriptions of infection just
to go into a historical perspective back
in the day people finally understood
that those biomarkers that we're talking
about are not as specific as we thought
they were for infection and so dr. bone
in an article that was published in 1991
came up with the concept of serves the
inflammatory response syndrome which if
there is an infection present denote
sepsis if there is no infection present
denotes sterile inflammation so
basically not all patients
who have an elevated white count fever
Mandy Mia low blood pressure tachycardia
tachypnea
are infected if they are then they have
sepsis if they are infected and they
have organ failure we call that severe
sepsis if they have low blood pressure
and elevated lactate levels we call that
septic shock this has recently been
modified
last year I guess it was 2016 and they
changed it a little bit to make it more
specific they thought and sensitive and
so the server's criteria are left out
because sirs doesn't denote infection
infection denotes infection infection in
organ damage is now considered to be
sepsis and then infection organ failure
with low blood pressure and/or
an elevated lactate level denotes septic
shock and the big difference in the
lactate level between the older and
newer criteria is the level in the older
criteria was four-and-a-half millimoles
and now it's two millimoles in reality
though these are nice for classification
and for identification of risk but
what's the most important thing is not
that to a clinician is is the guy
infected does he have sepsis and sadly
neither of these two schemes tell us
that we have to figure that out for
ourselves and one of the ways to figure
that out for ourselves is to measure
biomarkers in the new criteria when I'm
not going to belabor this we use
specific criteria for organ failure -
denotes substance so that everyone will
be on the same page when they're
identifying organ failure this is the
sequential organ failure assessment or
the sulfur scale that's how we identify
that okay what about
the newer guidelines with respect to
identification and usage of antibiotics
and patients with infections so for the
longest time in the United States we lag
behind our European brethren they have
been using biomarkers for antimicrobial
stewardship as well as identification
for sepsis
for at least a decade before we got
going but finally now in the surviving
substance guidelines for 2016 we can see
that the expert panel believes that the
measurement of procalcitonin levels can
be used to support shortening the
duration of antimicrobial therapy what
does that mean it means that we can now
titrate antibiotics to a specific
patient and infection as opposed to just
some global algorithm that is supposed
to be okay for everybody which we know
it's not most importantly when the
levels become very low they now suggest
that we can use those levels to
discontinue empiric therapy so if we've
started the patient on therapy we now
can look at sequential procalcitonin
levels and when they become very low
typically ninety percent of peak level
we can stop them in addition
we can use negative PCT levels to avoid
the use of antibiotics and people who
are not infected and we can also use
them to decide when patients who are
infected are not responding
appropriately to therapy
so typically procalcitonin has a
half-life of about 24 hours and so if
we're treating a patient appropriately
this biomarker should disappear by 50%
every day if it does not it would
suggest that there might be an infection
that we're not treating adequately again
they recommended the use of this
biomarker for treating patients with
hospital-associated infections and
ventilator associated infections so
there were separate papers dealing with
just infections in general and then H
caps and and baps as well so current
guidelines management of patients with
hospital-acquired and ventilator
associated pneumonia is we can use it to
discontinue antibiotic therapy we can
also do it to implement and antibiotic
stewardship program so that we can
overall reduce patient exposures to
antibiotics and there now when we look
into the critical care society finally
in 2017 and they have approved the use
of procalcitonin in their surviving
sepsis campaign guidelines again
reiterating what the IDSA had said
joining the duration of antibiotics and
for the discontinuation of antibiotics
especially in circumstances where we've
never actually been able to culture the
organism from the patient so most of the
time procalcitonin is used as a
corroboration for infection but
typically clinicians will start
antibiotics
even before the levels come back and
even if the levels initially are
negative because of the fact that they
can lag six to twelve hours be until
after presentation for patient however
when the PCT is negative two times and
these measurements have taken at least
12 hours apart typically they're done
every day so not 12 hours apart just
once a day then antibiotics are
typically discouraged in typical
protocols and data has suggested that it
is a very reasonable clinical thing to
do besides telling us when to stop
antibiotics procalcitonin can also help
us prognosticate so that we can
understand whether patients are going to
do well or poorly this was a paper that
I authored with Philip Chuck shoots and
others where we looked at the decline in
procalcitonin levels and as a function
of survival and what we found was that
when the levels declined at 72 hours by
80% from what they were at their highest
the mortality rate for severe sepsis and
septic shock was only 10 percent if the
procalcitonin levels did not decline by
80% under those circumstances the
mortality rate was 33% so it was three
times higher when the PCT levels did not
decline this was the Bennett basis for
the Moses study some of the data I will
be showing you here but I just wanted to
go through some other data to show the
benefit of procalcitonin in the American
literature over the last decade these
are multiple different studies where we
looked at either discontinuing or
continuing antibiotics with lower
respiratory tract infections based on
PCT levels and so here what you can see
is that in the vast majority of
the studies PCT demonstrated a benefit
here is a stud one of the exceptions
this study over here by Kristofferson
did not show benefit but all the other
studies did show a benefit for
procalcitonin this was a study that also
I possibly should have presented this
before now basically this basically
tells us why we cannot necessarily wait
for the procalcitonin levels to become
positive to start antibiotics because
what this study showed was that once the
patient presents to the emergency room
there is a seven percent increase in
mortality relative 7 percent the
mortality rate only goes up by seven
percent of what the patients would have
been so the mortality rate for that
patient was twenty percent it goes up by
one point four percent but it does that
every hour and so we cannot afford to
delay administering antibiotics but if
the PCT levels come back negative
we will DC the antibiotics typically at
24 hours so early recognition of sepsis
is really important in order to improve
the outcomes for these patients
but sometimes patients will present with
elevated procalcitonin levels in whom
somebody did not expect the patient to
have an infection okay so this is a a
substance algorithm that was promoted by
the Moses trial so patients who are
diagnosed with severe sepsis and septic
shock they looked at the change in PCT
levels over the first four days if the
levels change by less than 80 percent
the patient had a high mortality rate
risk if the PCT levels change by more
than 80 percent there was a lower so
this was the Moses trial this is the
trial that got the FDA to
to increase the statements that could be
used about procalcitonin use increase
it's used clinically we can look at some
additional studies that show that p CT
guidance significantly reduces the
duration of exposure to antibiotics for
patients with sepsis so this this was a
a meta-analysis and you can see that
using these cut-off levels you can
actually significantly reduce exposure
without increasing adverse events
obviously that would be an importance
this was for everybody on antibiotics
and you can see that the antibiotics
exposure starting at day three was
statistically significant and it stayed
significant till almost a month later
these are data from randomized
controlled trials that show that there
was no adverse association with reducing
antibody exposures under those
circumstances so you can see that
although they were patients were exposed
significantly less antibiotics there was
no increased mortality can we use this
around the hospital yeah this study
showed that you can get the benefit if
you use it in the IDI anyplace in the
hospital gives you a similar benefit in
community acquired pneumonia there was a
benefit acute exacerbations of COPD
possibly one of the most significant
benefits these patients always have
coughed a lot of them have chronic
sputum production and then they get
short of breath it is so difficult
clinically to identify whether there's
an infection so these patients receive
antibiotics typically 5 to 7 days and we
knew that only half of these patients
actually have bacterial infections we
just didn't know from the get-go
well procalcitonin this biomarker can
actually help us identify that and you
can see the dramatic reduction in
antibiotic exposure in acute
exacerbations of COPD which is still one
of the most prevalent
things that we see in emergency
departments okay
sorry about I don't know if you see that
yellow thing there you weren't supposed
it anyhow PCT in my hospital I was an
early adapter I did this because so many
patients were coming up from the
emergency department on in antibiotics
and my colleagues wanted to continue
them but I could not see that the
patient had an infection so we were
looking for something that would help us
and so we became an early adapter so
we've been using it this slide is
actually a little old it's now nine
years and we we draw about 200 PCT
levels a month and used to be solely in
the ICU but now it's used in the
emergency department as well as on the
general medical floors okay so those are
the introductory remarks and I know that
took up a good portion of the hour but
we're going to go through some some
cases these are not really exciting sexy
cases but they do demonstrate how to use
the biomarker
okay so first patient presents nausea
vomiting abdominal pain did some liver
function test their abnormal they were
obstructed people are believing that the
station has ascending cholangitis
patients elevated no left shift lipase
was normal which helped rule out the
possibility of pancreatitis so the
patient gets resuscitated with some
fluids antibiotics to start started
cultures are obtained and of course
we're not going to get results on these
cultures because we don't do PCR at our
Hospital probably for 48 maybe 72 hours
so let's do some biomarker evaluations
okay so this is what the biomarker
evaluation look like on the initial
presentation you can see that the PCT
was initially point two it was low and
the lactate level was elevated
okay so based on the presentation would
we suggest that antibiotics or working
on this patient or not why don't you
guys respond now and I think I will get
a real-time poll and how long after the
onset of antibiotic beginning should we
discontinue the antibiotics and I guess
the choices that you have in front of
you are from day one to day five so if
you guys could submit that and then
we'll go on and see what happens okay
initially the PCP level is negative the
lactate level is high and as we
resuscitate the patient we see that the
lactate level disappears pretty quickly
so you can see that within a half a day
that's what point five do you mean the
lactate level returns to normal so right
now at 12 hours into our hospitalization
we have a negative PCT and we have a
normalization of lactate now 86% of you
guys wanted to continue antibiotics
because you thought they were working
and and I think that's quite a
reasonable conclusion and about half of
you wanted to continue antibiotics for
at least five days the other half
actually pretty aggressive in
discontinuing the antibiotics but look
what happens on day one so 24 hours
after the patients in the hospital we
actually repeat the PCT and now look at
it's 10 despite the fact that lactate
level has normalized
but of course to lactate and PCT looking
at different things procalcitonin is
looking at whether the body thinks it's
infected lactate is looking at whether
you fixed perfusion and you did
perfusion is great infection still
ongoing
this will stay elevated until we get
adequate antibiotic levels in the
tissues to force the body's response to
to get rid of the bacteria and so in
fact you can see here that the PCT
levels are actually the same 48 hours
later but now you can see on day three
there was about a 50% reduction on day
four a 50% reduction and on day five a
even greater reduction and so those of
you who thought that stopping
antibiotics of a five would be a great
idea that would be okay and in fact one
could argue that day four might be just
a little bit too early because there's
only about an 80% a little bit less than
eighty percent decline there but now you
can see the difference between the two
biomarkers one is talking about the
adequacy of perfusion one is the
adequacy of infection control
okay so not to belabor the point
we gave the patients antibiotics
resuscitation made the patient
significantly better patient actually
had a great outcome okay so now we have
two cases which I call case two scenario
one in case two scenario two because the
two patients presented almost at the
same time four hours apart they had
almost the same history but quite
different clinical outcomes so the first
patient was a female was showing us of
breath some hypoxia patchy infiltrates
on chest x-ray the white count was
elevated there was a little bit of his
ships to the left she had some sputum
production no subjective fever okay so
now we get some biomarkers and the
biomarkers demonstrate to us on day one
that the patient has a negative PCT and
a positive lactate level
okay well still Clippy pneumonia
seems like it might be heart failure
based on the x-ray and clinical scenario
but can't not treat her at least
initially because the infiltrates and
the elevated white count for an ammonia
we're going to allow the PCT to help us
identify what is really going on in this
patient and so 24 hours later we repeat
the PCT and you can see that it's 4.2
I'm sorry the lactate level is 4.2 the
PCT is negative okay so we have now two
PCT levels that are pristine 24 hours
apart
probability of infection less than 2%
stop antibiotics lactate levels elevated
this patients in heart failure so this
patient does not need antibiotic therapy
this patient needs therapy for her heart
okay
presentation it was another woman a few
years younger nonetheless basically with
the same story almost identical chest
x-rays difference was when the sputum
did show a little bit of sputum
production and so we're going to pull
again here first
what would this pattern indicate when we
look at it initially we have a negative
P CT and a positive lactate but at 24
hours we now have a positive p CT and
the lactate has improved so would this
suggest a bacterial infection a viral
infection from pneumonia or do we still
need additional workup if you guys could
vote now that would be great okay the
second question that I'm going to ask
about this does this patient have severe
sepsis
this one's easy either yes or no and you
guys could respond to that one as well
okay well this patient was started on
antibiotics and you can see that there
is a nice decline in PCT over time and
this indicates to us that the patient
has had an appropriate response at this
point in time the patient was
transferred out of the ICU but still on
antibiotics there there was there was
still significant infection present so
we did not stop antibiotics but here is
the beauty of this these two patients
had almost the exact same clinical
history the chest x-rays were almost
indistinguishable one of them had just
heart failure one of them had pneumonia
one needed antibiotics and got it the
other one didn't need antibiotics and
only got antibiotics for 24 hours let's
see how you guys did okay we all
identified that this patient had a
bacterial infection
and we did quite well there about 66% of
you guys thought that and 61% says the
patient had severe sepsis and that would
be correct because the patient actually
had septic shock because the lactate
level was elevated and the patient did
have an infection so good good work
nicely done
maybe you could teach my fellows that
okay case three today history of
diarrhea and fever the patient had
recently undergone a revision of hip
surgery patient was exposed to
antibiotics for 48 hours to prevent post
off infection she presents with a normal
white count but with a left shift a
temperature to 101 and a hot rate of 107
so she has all the service criteria and
some criteria to make us think that she
might be infected abdomen was distended
and tender she had dilation of the small
bowel we are now suspecting that this
might be an antibiotic induced C
difficile overgrowth and infection and
in fact these are the PCT levels that
you will now see initially she presented
with a PCT level of 16 way.i I mean less
than 0.1 is normal so this is very
significantly elevated 160 times normal
okay
the lactate level was okay it was one it
was not abnormal at all the patient has
started on antibiotic therapy for c-diff
and the white count goes up to eighty
nine thousand I'm sorry the PCT goes up
to eighty nine this is okay for 24 hours
after appropriate therapy the PCT can
rise and it will rise to the level that
is commensurate with how sick the
patient really is okay so one two eighty
nine this is a pretty sick person if you
remember that dose response curve then
it shows you early in the Elector
this person is way up there but we do
see that there is a response it goes
down to 64 then it goes down by half but
then over here it only goes down by
about a third and then here it goes down
only by a quarter and actually here it's
going up this should never happen we
were very concerned right between day 5
and day six when the PCT is not
responding appropriately something bad
is happening the patient ended up having
a perforation with massive peritonitis
soiling of her abdominal space the
infection became overwhelming with
multiple different organisms and then
you can see on the 8th the level went up
to 199 and finally to 99 and sadly the
patient expired
okay last case this is a patient who
presented with urosepsis oh I'm sorry
this is just a rehash of the previous
case okay here we go we have a patient
with urosepsis symptoms were frequency
and dysuria urinalysis was positive
white cells bacteria leukocyte esterase
and nitrates were positive okay so we
bring the patient in Taniya tells care
unit because as you can see the lactate
level was very significantly elevated
and then we put the patient in the
septic shock range okay
and so we resuscitate the patient next
day the PCT didn't go down very much but
as I pointed out this is okay this does
not necessarily mean a treatment failure
lactate as you can see did respond very
nicely but here's the problem at 48
hours the PCT should be declined by 50%
and it's not and so the things we
consider here did we miss the
appropriate infection maybe this was in
urine tract infection we're treating it
with the incorrect antibiotics or is
there a protected source is this an
abscess is there some reason that my
antibiotics cannot get to with their
bacteria are to kill them the the levels
go up even further on day four we get an
ultrasound and we find that this is a
protected focus we find an abscess in
her kidney so there was a perinephric
abscess we sent it down to
interventional radiology the patient's
abscess was drained and we bring her
back to the ICU afterwards and I guess
for some reason I am not getting the
slide which would demonstrate that the
patient had a very nice up was not
getting that slide I I apologize what
would have happened
the next slide would have been that the
patient had demonstrated a very nice
response to antibiotic therapy with a
decline of PCT of about fifty percent a
day until the abscess was completely
drained and the infection was completely
gone so to summarize what we have now
for the first time is a biomarker which
doesn't look at the macro response of
the body to inflammation and or
infection but is a very specific
cellular response to the presence of
bacteria in the environment and this
response increases in response to the
intensity of the infection so that it
can tell you how sick the patient is at
presentation when the antibiotic therapy
is successful the signal disappears with
a half-life of about 24 hours and so
that you can actually monitor the
response to know whether your response
is effective so you don't have to rely
on the fever curve which may be
difficult to interpret because of
antipyretics or the white count which
always was difficult to interpret
because it seemed to disappear way
faster then the patient was getting
better we can titrate antibiotic therapy
specifically to the response of this
patient and then finally if you think
the guy's infected but the procalcitonin
levels are negative times to at least
spaced by 12 hours then your impression
probably was incorrect and you can stop
antibiotics right then and there
so we now have a tool that can help us
look into what the body is responding to
how they're responding how appropriately
we are treating them not from external
signals but from internal signals thank
you for your attention and I would be
more than happy to handle any questions
that may have arisen during this talk
dr. clerk thank you so much for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have any questions you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the green Q&A button of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for so
let's take a look at our questions from
our audience members now doctor look our
first question coming in is what is the
protocol or clinical algorithm that you
currently use your practice to manage
sepsis patients so if we have a patient
who presents with a reasonable clinical
history of sepsis the protocol is to do
adequate fluid resuscitation draw
procalcitonin levels and start the
culture of the patient and then start
the patient on antibiotics using an
empiric regimen based on the site of
infection we then do serial
procalcitonin measurements to one
identify whether in fact this was an
infection and the response so if we have
two negative P CTS then we actually
discontinue antibiotic therapy the
pharmacist at our Hospital will go
around we'll evaluate and look at the
PCT levels and if they are negative they
will put a stop order in antibiotics if
they're positive they'll keep the
antibiotics going until the PCT levels
are less than 90 percent of what they
were at their peak we use this protocol
in the ICU and also on the general
medical floors we also use this protocol
for the early identification of sepsis
in our patients so in the event that the
nurse has a patient - white cell count
comes back elevated on a CBC or the
patient develops a fever or tachycardia
or other signs or symptoms of an
infection the nurse on the floor has the
ability to order
a CBC a lactate level and a
procalcitonin level so that these data
can be acquired more rapidly so that
when the physician arrives at the
bedside to help evaluate this patient
with the nurse these data are readily
available and better clinical decisions
can be made thank you doctor God and
here's our next question from our
audience
how has implementation of PCT improved
patient outcomes so two things one that
is published one that is not yet
published the first thing that's
published is what we found out that
we're using a lot less antibiotics and
we figured out why we're using a lot
less antibiotics because we have a huge
number of people who are started on
antibiotics but are stopped at 24 hours
when the PCT levels are negative five
years ago eight years ago ten years ago
that could not have happened those
patients probably would have gotten the
full course of antibiotics mostly
because a negative culture doesn't mean
the patient's not infected so they would
have gotten the antibiotics
so we are we're down probably about 50
to 55 percent in our antibiotic usage
number two data that we are now
accumulating and should have ready for
publication surely his RC differet has
done down significantly in the ICU we
were getting on average 15 to 18 cases
per year of seed if we're down to four
and the initial analysis demonstrates
that there is a significant correlation
with the seed if in patients who have
gotten cereal PCT levels and in those
patients who and antibiotics stopped so
these data which will be ready for
publication very shortly
thank you doctor luck and thank you
audience member we have a wonderful
active
audience today our next question is any
are there any correlation between PCT
levels and g- and g+ orga organisms as
the source of sepsis so turns out PCT
responds more vigorously in gram
negative organisms only because the cell
responds more aggressively for whatever
reason to gram negative the cell has the
toll receptors that is equal for both
gram positive and gram negatives but
there is in addition in a little pile of
saccharide receptor on the cells and LPS
is only from gram negative so there are
a there is another set of receptors on
the cells just for gram negatives and
both of those will stimulate PCT
production so there seems to be a more
vigorous response to gram negatives than
gram positives GI infections have the
highest response as far as levels
pneumonia in between your na tract and
skin the lowest so it is dependent also
on the immuno competency of the tissue
and since the GI tract is has to be
tremendously immuno confident because
all the bacteria that are nearby when
it's not surprising that that has the
biggest response thank you so much and
here's our next question how do you
explain the negative PCT level at day
one for all three patients patient is
presented considering that a rapid
increase would be expected so I
specifically picked those those cases as
a teaching point what I don't want
people to think is that a single
negative PCT level means there is no
infection and so I only picked cases
where the PCT level is negative that
presentation however over the course of
the nine years that we've been using
and other people and recorded the exact
same results in an average hospital
community type hospital about one third
of your patients will present with a
negative PCP level two thirds will
present with a positive one at the and
when they come to the IDI or to the ICU
or whatever so although it would appear
from my slide presentation that that was
the universal situation it actually is
the minority of situations but it does
help me make my teaching point which i
think is a very important one that in
order to exclude an infection you need
to PCT levels at least 12 hours apart
thank you dr. Lycan here's a related
question during early the early part of
your presentation we were trying to
confirm whether bacterial infections
exist but PCT levels are still low how
often would you recommend testing PCT
during the first 24 hours wait since the
person is going to get antibiotics no
matter what are the first dose and since
the beauty of antibiotics now is that
they have such a long half-life and we
don't have to give very many of very
many doses of them
I only measure the PCT every 24 hours
now the arete eclis there might be a
circumstance where you might want to do
one at 12 hours let's suppose you had a
patient with meningitis and you really
needed to know whether it's bacterial or
viral and the first PCT was negative
because the mom brought the baby in for
instance let's say very early that might
be a circumstance where you might want
to test more often than once a day
but since the half-life is 24 hours once
you've established that the person is
infected you do not need to test PCT any
more often than once a day
thank you and thank you audience for our
active participation our next question
comes from across the world is there an
advantage to initiating antibiotic
treatment
a patient presenting with elevated il-6
if one could get il-6 npc t levels there
would be but il-6
is a relatively nonspecific inflammatory
mediator as well if for instance you had
a trauma to your leg your il-6 levels
would be elevated whether or not there
was an infection but if the il-6 levels
were elevated and you were waiting for
the PCT levels to become positive at
least that would tell you that there was
some degree of an inflammation in the
body and that would make it more likely
than antibiotics was going to be the
right answer but il-6 TNF are very
nonspecific very similar in scope to
c-reactive protein but even more
globally responsive to almost any form
of inflammation where C reactive protein
typically responds to a inflammatory
pattern that is lymphocytic induced
thank you and how do you address or
balance a submission use or abuse the
PCT usage from a lab point view well in
the big deal about abuse of any lab
tests is the cost
fortunately the cost is very small
second lab time
the test is automated so it's not a big
deal as far as extra lap time so here's
the point if a patient's on antibiotics
then there is absolutely no good reason
not to do PCT levels at worse don't
corroborate you're doing the right thing
at best they'll say oh this patient
doesn't need
buttocks or this patient you can stop
the antibiotics today you don't have to
wait till tomorrow the day after and the
cost of the test relative to a day of
antibiotics makes it almost a no-brainer
it's much more cost-effective to
measures PCT level serially than to use
clinical judgment with antibiotics alone
and and with stopping antibiotic therapy
early based on the PCT results leading
to antibiotic resistance no actually we
think it's just the opposite
basically antibiotic resistance comes
from a genetic fluke bacteria exposed to
an antibiotic they are trying to defend
themselves they're making all these
proteins and eventually they hit the
right one and they become the dominant
bacteria and so now we have a resistant
organism if you only expose them to very
short amounts of antibiotics because
they are not infected then the
possibility of that bacteria becoming
resistance is actually decreased so we
think that one of the communal benefits
of using this biomarker would actually
be just the opposite a reduction in the
potential for resistant organisms and
would you recommend having PCT on every
patient who presents in ER for suspected
service success if you are a discerning
ER doc and you think that they have
suspected sepsis absolutely it doesn't
help the ER guy that much but it helps
the guy who's going to be taking care of
him after he leaves the ER I mean if the
PCT levels negative and they send them
home and the doc looks at the guy he has
to know that the PCT level was negative
this person may have a syndrome that is
mimicking an infection but is not and if
the patient's admitted then we already
have a baseline level so that we can see
if the patient's responding to therapy
but as far as the decision-making for
the ER guy they are still going to have
to use their clinical judgment because
they're only going to have a single PCT
level when the patient presents so
they're going to if the patient has a
low idea I mean if the clinician has a
low index of suspicion then a negative
PCT may be enough to stop not to give
antibiotics in the first place if the
patient has a moderate in a you know
index and suspicion and the levels
elevated well that's going to push that
index of suspicion to very high so yeah
I think the ER guys need to use their
clinical judgment obviously this will
help them make better decisions and
doctors what are the guidelines that are
recommended to use PCT and diagnostic
substance in ICU yeah actually the
original guidelines from the FDA were
all about ICU patients and they have now
been supplemented by the IDSA guidelines
and the SCCM guidelines because the
original guidelines did not talk about
hospital-associated infections and
ventilator associated infections but
they did always identify patients who
presented to emergency ICU in in
prognostication of who was sick and who
is not based on the initial levels that
were obtained thank you and here's
another question regarding guidelines
beside the surviving sepsis guidelines
will PCT be incorporated in any other
governing guidelines example CDC
guidelines I do believe that since the
FDA has approved this these statements
that they will be part of the government
guidelines what we're waiting to see is
whether the CMS guidelines right now the
CMS guidelines to tell you what you have
to do in the emergency department and
elsewhere when you identify patient it
must be infected they are not part of
those guidelines as of yet lactate is
dct is not but those guidelines were
created a year before the fda approved
these additional claims for PCT so we'll
have to see I think that they will be
included but I can't be hundred percent
sure thank you so much we have time for
one more question our next question is
how does PCT use differ between an adult
versus a pediatric patient population it
really shouldn't neonates that's a
different story when people and when a
baby is born the immune system goes
through very very dramatic changes for
the first 72 hours so the guidelines
they are very different but the
pediatric and adults should respond
exactly the same this is not something
that you that you gain once you go
through puberty or anything like that
studies and Pediatrics has shown that
it's just as useful in pediatric
patients as it is in adults the only
thing that's different is the type of
infections that kids get and the levels
that you might consider abnormal in in
them as far as I know point 5 is still
the threshold that most people use as
reasonably positive to the point where
the likelihood of false positive is
small so I would assume they're using
the same levels in pediatrics
but I don't take care of those kids so I
don't know for sure but there the data
is very significant in that it should
work just as well in kids as it does in
adults dr. Clark thank you again for
your presentation and audience thank you
so much for your live participation we
want to let you know that um your
further questions will be answered via
email dr. Webb did you want to provide
the audience with any closing remarks
before we close our presentation today I
think I gave a nice little summary
before we did the question and answer so
now I'm good I'm really glad that I got
the opportunity to speak to you guys
today and I hope you enjoyed the talk we
did and thank you again for your
presentation and your important research
I'd also like to thank lab roots and
Abbott for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through April 2018 you'll receive an
email from lab roots letting you know
when this webcast will be available for
replay please share that announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
and thanks everyone for joining us we
hope to see you again soon goodbye